UCP leader Danielle Smith posing for a
photograph with three Ottawa Convoy
participants days before an election in
Alberta officially begins her political
opponents say it's a bad look the
premier is deciding to hang out with
these people with extreme views some of
them having criminal charges as well the
three in the photo along with Smith
Harold Yonker a convoy protester and
town counselor in the Niagara region who
was found to be in breach of that Town's
code of conduct Sandra bowder and her
husband James both charged with Mischief
disobeying a lawful court order and
resisting a peace Officer James played a
lead role in the Ottawa Convoy the
public inquiry into the public order
emergency references him and his wife 56
times he was one of the co-authors of
this power sharing Arrangement that they
were going to deliver to the governor
general basically stripping Trudeau in
the Canadian House of Commons of any
Authority that power was going to be
shared between the Senate and uh and the
Convoy organizers but the UCP says
there's no connection to Smith in a
statement of global news the party says
in full as usual the premier took part
in a routine photo lineup with nearly
200 people last night the premier does
not personally know these individuals
there seems to be a repeated pattern all
related around covet that Daniel Smith
keeps sticking her foot into earlier
this month Smith faced more backlash
after Calgary Street Preacher Archer
palowski met with her while facing
charges related to the Coots blockade
but political scientist Wayne Bratt says
these types of photos and meetings
likely won't make much of a difference
in the looming campaign there's going to
be one view that just says here here's
another example and another view that
says uh you know this is no big deal you
know notley's worse and then there's
going to be a subsection that's going to
be cheering around despite that the end
DP are trying to bring these instances
front and center premium need to explain
to albertans that why people like
uh
James butter people like kill flurry
people like Arthur palwalski have
previous ears the Writ drops Monday
election day is May 29th safe Kaiser
Global News